um two of the trends that I know that
you spent a lot of time are on maybe
because you guys have a portfolio
companies is one ecommerce and then to
kind of add spend or the advertising
industry let's start with e-commerce
what are you guys seeing there on the
e-commerce side that you think is either
interesting or people should should be
paying attention to I mean look I think
this is a it's been a great time for
e-commerce generally to show the world
that it really meant like the variable
cost of an e-commerce business are
really important you know if you think
about how an e-commerce business is
built you know its cogs its your sort of
software services your website stuff
like that and it's marketing spend and
you have employees if you're a big
e-commerce company you might have a
warehouse and inventory by the way you
have your inventory lender you know God
knows they don't want your inventory
because if you can't sell it they can't
sell it and then you might have more
employees at normal but by the way if
you haven't warehouse you probably have
more cash than the average small
business maybe but you can toggle that
up and down if you have a physical
retail location you have your rent you
have a lot of fixed costs that you can't
toggle up and down and on top of that
people can still shop online so
ecommerce our hypothesis right now is
it's gonna be hit a lot less badly than
most it's really hard to predict where
consumer demands gonna go down as more
and more people are laid off it's gonna
be bad however like you know I know I I
probably spent a third of what I
normally spend last month because I'm
just not going out and not doing stuff
so I have you know the average
individual is probably generating more
excess cash if they are employed they
may go online and shop that's what I
mean by you know in one hand you could
be an e-commerce company say oh my god
now's a great time to play offense
because I know where the world is going
all my competitions going down but
there's so many competing variables that
like okay so people are spending less
maybe they have more time to shop online
um people are getting laid off maybe
demands gonna go down you know it's just
too hard like it's too hard to know so
you know I can't give too much
confidential information on e-commerce
other than those sort of general data
points on advertising you know we're
seeing a handful of sort of factors one
is views are way up
people are at home there on screens and
are watching more and CPMs are way down
part of the reason CPMs are down is
because if you were spending a million
dollars a month and that was your budget
and now the use have doubled your CPI
owns will just come down in half but you
know you're seeing slight decreases in
ad spend right now in the last two weeks
of March you're seeing way more views
than normal and different parts of the
ad market I get got to get hit
differently you know print radio TV
things that are hard to measure and are
expensive are gonna get really hit
social video just you know banner ads
less hit because they're easier to
measure and the CPMs are cheaper and so
you can get a better bang for your buck
you know and then by the way if you
really are some people give your peloton
or your Hulu or your something like that
you're gonna get a better ROI on your ad
spend now than ever and so you might
start leaning in because there's less
noise
so we're basically seeing ads CPM is
coming way down views going way up and
ad spend generally being down 5 to 20
percent depending on the medium and I
can imagine as been going down 20 to 50
percent but that some platforms are
gonna perform way better than others and
I would be pretty bearish on media
companies that sell premium high CPMs
and more bullish on media companies that
have exchanges and so generally lower
CPMs snap sells at a lower CPM than
Instagram
that's a bullish comment youtube sells a
lower CPM than instagram
that's a bluish comment you know thing
the other thing is on you know Spotify
people aren't turning off their Spotify
subscriptions and the last thing that
sort of is an interesting observation is
companies are turn people have
traditionally looked at LTVs and an
enterprise sales revenue as stickier
than consumer generated revenue like a
Netflix subscription feels less sticky
than enterprise software for enterprise
software that you see a bigger dip then
you see in consumer apps because people
are still at home watching Netflix
and they don't have a CFO of their
personal life negotiating with all their
different vendors and Netflix doesn't
care about any one subscriber but if
you're 2% of the revenue of a company or
if you're even 20 basis points of
revenue of a company that's huge and so
I bet you end up seeing more negotiation
and decrease the prices of enterprise
softening you see a consumer yeah that
makes sense when you put it that way
does this change you think people's view
of kind of ad-supported businesses
versus subscription businesses like what
exactly what you're talking about almost
changing the way that people think about
how they build their business in the
future I think that uh you know
enterprise software will probably be
thought of as cyclical going forward I
think one of the things that people you
know we talk a lot about internally is
what does the consumer cap stack look
like and historically
you know you've always said okay well
you know your home loan and your auto
loan or probably the most senior and
then it's like you know utility bills
and then it's like credit card and then
it's like unsecured stuff and then it's
like you're Nordstrom's card and you
look at default rates per consumer and
you kind of like go up and down that
stack just like a corporate you know cap
stacking says you have your senior
letter your secured lenders your on
secured lenders whatever and then what
we've always thought is Spotify
subscription like whatever your cheapest
per utility subscriptions are probably
more senior in your consumer cap stack
than most people think so I would
probably want to finance someone's
Spotify subscription before I'd want to
be their credit card provider because I
bet you you don't pay your credit card
bill but you still maybe find a way to
pay your Spotify bill the flipside that
argument as you pay your Spotify bill is
your credit card I don't know maybe but
man does it feel good to be providing
this a $9 $0.99 per month service that
is probably being used a ton if you're
out of work or your smartphone or
Netflix compared to like a credit card
so it's just it'll be interesting I
think we're gonna have a bunch of new
data around what default rates on what
churn looks like after this that we
never had before
yeah did the thing I think I run the ad
supported businesses too is that
advertiser who had the million bucks and
you know views have gone up two times so
now all of a sudden they're paying 50%
less CPMs at some point if we stay in
is quarantine I wonder if there's an
impact on sales that changes their CAC
and LTV calculations right so literally
just because you have the million
dollars to advertise if no one's buying
your product at some point do you
literally just say hey we're not gonna
advertise right so well it almost like
dries up because sales dry up yeah I
mean I think people are definitely start
running bearable and base case LTVs you
know one of the things that people
always say like LTV has become this sort
of like initially kakda LTV was
everyone's like holy grail metrics and I
think in the last couple years people
become a lot less enchanted by LTVs
because what you do is you take your
monthly revenue and you take six months
of total churn data and assume that's
what's gonna last forever and you come
up with some number that looks very
close to infinity in terms like what
your LTV is and I think people are gonna
start to say like what is your LTV in
different environments so I do you think
that it's actually going to become a
more useful metric again because you
we're going to know how to measure it
instead of just looking at it's like oh
don't worry my turn in my first four
months is zero so it means that my LTV
is like 93 quadrillion you know so I
also think that we're going I think the
last crisis saw a shift towards digital
ads and I think that you're gonna see
another shift there away from print TV
and traditional sources and I don't
think people gonna be really doing a lot
of billboard ads right now that doesn't
seem like a very good idea you know so I
think you're gonna see somewhat
permanent chefs but I also think that
you're gonna see you know companies like
the New York Times and others who have
relied on premium CPMs they've already
started going more and more towards
subscription revenue again in paid
revenue and I think as things like kovat
show it's how much bad information there
is out there if you're gonna keep paid
up I know that I've picked up probably
two to four subscriptions
well I've been home I'm just reading
more and watching more I don't think I'm
gonna turn off of them I think that's
gonna be the deal that's plug in via
forever shift yeah you know what you're
also like on the subscription side
there's some things you know we don't
watch a Netflix show every single night
right but it's something that is cheap
enough where I couldn't even actually
tell you how much it is is it 9 bucks 10
bucks 12 bucks whatever eyes when you
say not watching every night you're not
looking me into that right because I am
yeah but it's like let's say that you've
got I don't know most people probably
have somewhere between 4 to 10
subscriptions right that they're paying
for across various services and some of
those like a Spotify you probably
actually do use every day right if you
go to the gym you listen podcast
whatever put that other things you may
use once or twice a week and some of you
actually may only use once or twice a
month and what I think starts to happen
is the businesses themselves will
actually change the way that they think
about the proctor service right the more
that you can kind of become a daily
habit I think also changes and so it
almost then brings you to something like
a kwibi versus a Netflix right where
these the kwibi thing is basically 10
minutes short-form content you're
supposed to have a consume it you know
much quicker
yeah cetera versus let's sit down and
watch an hour-and-a-half documentary I
don't know if it'll prove out but but I
think that that has to enter the
conversation at some point for people
who are looking at the
subscription-based businesses as well
the kwibi thing will be interesting I
mean I think a lot of like I'm not I
don't know jack about storytelling
except did I always remember and I
actually used I'm on a board with kind
of put the construct for built the
contract for me he's like you know if
you look at John Christian book John
Grisham does this awesome thing where he
creates like you know very short
chapters and he always has three
subplots running and so at the end of
every chapter you have a subplot that
gets extinguished and you're really
interested to know it's gonna burst
right on a cliff like on a cliffhanger
and you get to the next chapter you're
sort of wondering so you read that
chapter to keep getting to the next
chapter we're gonna find out and then
there's another cliffhanger then you
read the third chapter another
cliffhanger you finally get the answer
to the first cliffhanger and then you
creates another right and so if quibble
you can kind of create that dynamic with
their audience where there's always a
cliffhanger where you come back the next
day I think that'd be interesting
I don't know that'll be true or not who
knows but I do agree that this daily
habit thing is important and I do agree
that cost per utility of use is going to
be a really really important metric you
know what's the value like I wonder if
there's gonna be a KPI that starts
coming out which is how much do people
spend for every
they're on Netflix and I bet you if you
looked at like the $9.99 you pay for
Netflix and you look at and then you
divide that by how many minutes per
month that'd be super fascinating to
know that metric compared to Hulu
compared to Disney Plus the other thing
by the way that kwibi reminds me of is
it's a short-duration asset so in
lending like let's imagine you lend you
make 5 year loans you know in one piece
that's not so good because you have to
take a 5 year view on the economy a 5
year view on the company and so people
say well if you make a 30 day loan it's
really easy to predict what's gonna
happen in 30 days the problem is
something every once in a while it's not
right like I don't know maybe there's
gonna be some virus that starts in a
country and spreads to all the other
countries and everyone stays home for a
while right and you know that was gonna
happen all of a sudden your book of 30
day assets all gets correlated to one
and goes to zero because we all stop
paying payable at this month and then on
the 5 year loan you know you basically
look at your default rate and you say
well my annualized default rate for 2 to
3 months it's super bad but then over
the duration of the whole asset base you
know I had out of 5 years 6 really bad
months so the thing performed okay in
general but the short duration the asset
you know the more your whole thing can
get wiped out and if you look at the
effect of default rates often people say
oh well factoring for example is like 15
45 90 day receivables and you'll see the
fault rates in like the 2 to 4 percent
range sometimes you have to annualize
that out
so if you see 2% defaults every month
it's really the 24 percent default rate
kwibi I think will in some ways be
entered like in a similar thing where I
am curious how many false positives
you're gonna get where people download
kwibi but they can't get hooked on these
short stories and they just fall off
ladder now I'm not I'm a storyteller I
don't have good